[موسيقى]
هلو مرحبا بكم جميعا شكرا لانضمامكم الينا
اليوم موضوع هذه الجلسه هو حقوق المراه في
ايران ما هي الخطوات التاليه اشكركم على
انضمامكم الينا الهاشتاغ هو دبليو اي
وبامكانكم استخدام اي هاشتاغ ترغبون به
حول ايران والمراه الايرانيه المستلمه من
نساء مدهشات استضيفوهن اليوم ويستضيفوهن
منتدى الاقتصاد العالمي ومن النادر ان
نلتقي اشخاصا من امثالهم هنا معنا حسن وهي
المديره التنفيذيه بالانابه لمنظمه وومنز
رعد في الولايات المتحده
وهي ناشطه تهتم بحقوق الانسان من بريطانيا
ومسيح علي نجاد وهي صحفيه وناشطه في
الوكاله الامريكيه للاعلام العالمي سافسح
المجال للاسئله في نهايه الجلسه لمده ساعه
ولا اعتقد ان هذا الوقت سيكون كافيا
للتحدث عن شجاعه المراه الايرانيه التي
شاهدناها في العام
2022 وفي هذه اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها مش
كان افتخاري هي والده مهسا امين التي نادت
ابنتها قائله مهسا يا ليتك هنا لترى
العالم لاجمعه يقف مطالبا بحقوقك مازلت
واقفه حتى الان لان العالم يتعاطف معنا
وهذا ما قالته والدته ميكا شكرامي التي
قتلت في التظاهرات اليوم ذكرى عيد ميلادك
يا ابنتي الحبيبه اليوم اقول تهانينا
لاستشهادك هذه امثله قليله جدا عما يحصل
على الارض في ايران وسنتعرف على المزيد من
ضيوفنا الكرام مسيح اشكرك على انضمامك
الينا لا اعرف في اي بيت امن كنت قبل
مجيئك الى هنا لا تحددي لنا موقعه لكن ما
هي مدى صعوبه هروبك من مكان الى اخر في
دول نظمها امنه من النظام الايراني وهل
انت الوحيده التي تواجه هذه
الصعوباترا
رفاهيه لمن يتجرا على التحدث عن الاسلام
وياه وضد الايديولوجيا الاسلاميه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه نعم عيشوا في بيت
امن ولكن لا احد منا سيكون بامان مع وجود
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه وطالبان وداعش حياتي
منقلبه راسا على العقبه ولكن وزني 45
كيلوغرام فقط اعرف ان شعري كثير ولكنني لا
احمل سلاحا
هو صوتي هو حساباتي على التواصل الاجتماعي
وجريمه انني امنح الاصوات لامهات ميكا و
سريناز ومازاني واسمحي لي ان اضيف جمله ان
امي اخرى هي تجمعان جوليبو قالت لي خلال
احدى المقابلات انها على مدى عام كامل بكر
ثم قررت ان تجعل الطاغيه والقاتل يبكي انا
كابوس هذا النظام والده بريا بختاري في
السجن حاليا وارى عددا كبيرا من النساء
هنا واتمنى لو انضم الينا المزيد من
الرجال هذه الثوره تقوده المراه ولكننا
بحاجه الى المزيد من الرجال لدعمنا والده
ووالدته بريا كلاهما في السجن حاليا وهما
ليس بالمجرمين بل سجناء فقط لانهما سال من
قتل ابتنا ولماذا هذه جرينتهما ولهذا
السبب بصراحه لا اود ان اتحدث عن حياه
المنقلبه راسا على العاقل خارج ايران
لانني الى الفراش وانا اسمع اخبارها هؤلاء
المراهقين واستيقظ على اخبار اعتقال
والديهم ايضا
هذه هي الحقائق القتل والتعذيب
والاغتيالات والشوق والاغتصاب واخذ
الرهائن كلها امور موجوده في الحمض النووي
للجمهوريه
الاسلاميهها ثوره المراه حركه انتفاضه ام
هي ثوره عامه في ايران ام ثوره الشعب
الايراني ماذا نسميها
كل هذه الامور ولكن يجب ان نكون واضحين
منذ ربيع العربي والسودان في العام 2019
فشراره تلك الثورات كانت مقتل الرجال اما
شراره هذه الثوره فهي مقتل شابه ومحركها
هو المراه النساء كنا اول من خرجنا الى
الشارع وخلعنا الحجاب في تظاهرات سلميه
واشعلنا فيها النار وقمنا بقص شعرهن على
الرغم من مخاطر الاغتصاب والسجن والضرب
والزنج بهن في مراكز اعاده تاهيل نفسه
والقتل هذه الشجاعه تن بعدوها الى الاخرين
الامر الفريد الذي يميزها والذي دعى
كثيرين منا الى تسميتها ثوره بقياده
المراه هي ان المراه الايرانيه تمكنت من
تحفيز المجتمع بكمله بفهم مسائل المساواه
بين الجنسين وكل حقوق الانسان الاساسيه
الاخرى ولان ما سوف فتاه ايرانيه كرديه
فقد اضيف مكون الاثنيات والاقليه الى
المعادله اما الان فقد اضيفت قاعده الطبقه
المتوسطه الواسعه والرجال والنساء
الايرانيون كلهم يقفون جنبا الى جنب من
اجل الديمقراطيه مع فهم المساواه بين
الجنسين وحق والاثنيات والاقليه الدينيه
كل هذا مترابط واصبحت حركه مناصره
للديمقراطيه انا اسف
مها سامي
ليست الايرانيه الوحيده التي عانت في
ايران هناك نساء في هذه اللحظه في سجن
الين وسجون اخرى وحتى خارج السجون ممن
يعانين من التعذيب ما الذي جعل مهسا امين
الشراره لهذا الشيء الكبير الذي حصل في
الشارع
لاكثر من 40 عاما ونظام وسلبهن حقوقهن
الاساسيه منذ اعوام مثل قواعد الملبس او
حقوق المراه في الزواج او تربيه اطفالهم
واذا ما سمح لهن بالعمل هذه معركه مستمره
ولكن السؤال لماذا مهسا انني لماذا كانت
رده فعل قويه بهذا الشكل كانت ماسا بمثابه
القشه التي قسمت ظهر البعير باشكال عده
قمع مستمر منذ فتره طويله وما سعهقلت
لانها ارتدت الحجاب بشكل غير ملائم فكروا
في ذلك كيف يمكن تعريفه لا يمكن تعريفه
الامر موضوع وعشوائي حاله حال الكثير من
القوانين التي وضعها النظام من اجل
السيطره على النساء في ايران وهذه اللحظه
من الزمن لا تدور حول منسف بل حول كافه
الحقوق ومحاولات النظام لاسكات المراه منذ
اكثر من اربعين عاما وهذه اللحظه بالتحديد
قادتها المراه والفتيات وهي ثوره بقياده
المراه والفتيات ولكنها الان حركه شعب لان
الشعب الايراني هو الذي يعبر بصوته الان
ويقول كفى وان النظام لن يستمر بهذا الشكل
بعد الان انهم يطالبون بحقوقهم وعلينا ان
نتذكر ان الاشخاص الخارجين الى الشوارع
المتظاهرين هم اشخاصم طبيعيون مثلكم ومثلي
ومثل ومسيح وما زنين ويقفون مباشره في وجه
اسلحه النظام وهم مستعدون للمجازفه بكل
شيء فقط شخص المشكله واخبروا العالم بما
يجب ان يتغير وافضل ما بوسع العالم ان
يقوم به الان هو ان المجتمع الدولي يجب ان
يدعم المتظاهرين ويجبوا ان يساعد على
تحقيق التغيير وان يفرض الضغط لكي يصغي
النظام لمتطلبات المتظاهرين وان يشهد
التغييرات السياسيه وهذا لن يتحقق لوحده
كيف تمكنت كلها هؤلاء النساء من الوقوف
مطالبات بحقوقهن في وجهي مثل هذا العنف هل
تغير شيء بالمجتمع الايراني هذه ليست اولا
انتفاظا نشهدها ما الذي تغير بالنسبه
لهؤلاء النساء
بمثل هذه الحركه في الشارع
عايزين همم ومن جاء مورفيرس
مانجا مور سبور اعتقد ان النساء ازدادت
شجاعتهن واصبح الرجال داعمين لهن اكثر
كلما قتل النظام الايراني عددا اكبر
ازدادت عزيمه الشعب يقشعر بدني عندما
اشاهد ذلك بعد ما يقوم النظام باعدام احد
المتظاهرين نرى والدي القتيل في اليوم
التالي يحولان الجنازه الى تظاهره كبيره
احد الاباء من كردستان خلال الجنازه ومن
دون ان يبكي صرخ قائلا ان هذه الثوره
بحاجه الى الدماء وابني ضحى بحياته
ونبدا
الفيديو
قبل خروجها لتظاهر وكانت تقول ان امها
قلقه عليها وفي كل مره تقول ربما ستصبحين
مثل ماسا ربما سيقتلونك اناقه لقاء عليك
لا تخرجي الى الشارع وهي ردت عليها قائله
امي انا ميت اصلا لانه ليس لدي حلم ولا
يحق لي اختيار ملابسي ولا الحق في الحريه
والتصرف على الطبيعه عندما لا امتلك
الحريه فانا انسان ميت اصلا لقد اكتفى
الجميع هذه المره اصبحت وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي سلاحهم وهم يعرفون ذلك ويعرفون
انهم ليسوا لوحدهم ولهذا فهم هناك من اجل
انهاء النظام هذا نظام منفصل عنصري بين
الجنسين وادعوني اكون واضحه انت قولي لي
لو فرض عليكن القانون في بلادكم انكم من
عمري سبع سنوات لم تحصل على تعليمه وحرم
عليكم الرقص او الحصول على جواز السفر من
دون اذن والدن وبذلك لا تستطيع السفر ولا
يمكن كنا ركوب دراجه هوائيه او الذهاب الى
الملعب الرياضيه فقط لان ماذا ستفعلنا
انتن بحكم الموت اصلا ولهذا اناشد الجميع
بان لا يغدوا الطرف عم يحصل منذ اعوام
وانا احضر من شرطه الاخلاق والحجاب القسري
لانني اطلقت حمله في العام 2014 والكل في
الغرب طلب مني الصمت بدريعه انني انشر
الكراهيه ضد الاسلام
[موسيقى]
بفتره طويله جدا هذا الامر يخص الحجاب فقط
يا نازانين كذلك اود ان اسالك عندما تحفز
المراه على الثوره او الانتفاضه هل تنجح
عن
الحجاب اصبح رمز
14 عقود الفائته ومع ذلك ففي المجالات
التي يسمح لهن بدراسه فهن متعلمات اكثر من
الرجال وكل تلك المثابره اصبحت قوه دافعه
لهذه اللحظه بالذات واذا ما اضطلانا على
التاريخ من الارجنتين الى تشيلي الى
الفلبين فعندما تكون المراه في قلب الحركه
فلن احتمال نجاحها وانتصار الديمقراطيه
يزداد لماذا لان لدينا امكانيه الوصول الى
مفاصل السلطه وما هو شكل ذلك هناك فيديو
واسع الانتشار لامراه متقدمه في السن تذهب
الى ابنها الذي يعمل في قوه الامن قبل
مشاركته في عمليه قمع دمويه وتنطلق نحوه
وتمسك به من ذراعه وتقوده بعيدا عن
التظاهرات هذه هي قوه الثوره التي تقودها
المراه لماذا لاننا نستطيع ان نفعل ذلك
لدينا الامكانيه لان نقول لابنائنا بان
هذا العمل هو غير صحيح وهذه الشجاعه تنقل
عدوها الى الاخرين هذا ما نرى قوه الام
الاي عندما يقتل او يعدم طفلها هناك شعار
يقول كل شخص يقتل يقف الف شخص وراءه وهذا
بالضبط هو نراه
تقولين ان الحكومات ليست لديها الفرصه
فحسب انما هي مسؤوله وعليها التحرك من اجل
حمايه حقوق الانسان ماذا بوسع المجتمع
الدولي ان يفعله من اجل مساعده المراه
الايرانيه امم افريقيا
الاهم هو قدره التحمل السياسيه فقد شهدنا
مرارا وتكرارا ان القاده السياسيين في
العالم مستعيدون للتعبير عن دعمهم
للمتظاهرين ولكن كل ذلك يتراجع مع انتقال
الكاميرات لتغطيه احداث عالميه اخرى كم
يحصل غالبا وما يجب ان يضمنه هذه المره
وعلى سبيل المثال الرد على ما حصل في
اوكرانيا
ان يحصل عما يمكن ان يتحقق اذا ما وقفنا
في وجه اقوى الانظمه اذا ما تعاون المجتمع
الدولي مع بعضه نتوقع ذات درجه التضامن
ونفس العمل وبالقوه ذاتها من المجتمع
الدولي حي لايران ومواصله ذلك حتى النهايه
يجب ان نسمع الالتزامات التي تقدمها
الحكومات وان نقول باننا سنتاكد من
استمرارنا في تطوير العقوبات الهادفه على
سبيل المثال لضمان استمرار الضغط على
النظام
بوسع المجتمع الدولي للقيام بها على المدى
القصير من اجل تخفيف الضغط على الشعب مثل
اجراء تعديلات على العقوبات لنضمن التمكن
دخول بعض الاطراف الى ايران لدعم
المتظاهرين احدى المسائل التي نعاني منها
هي الحصول على معلومات دقيقه حيل اعداد
القتلى لا نستطيع التحقق من كل هذه
المعلومات فله تمكننا من تقديم من مساعده
ماديه للصحفيين المحلي لتقديم تقارير
ميدانيه فهذه التغييرات البسيطه من شانها
ان تكون قويه جدا في المستقبل اسمه
الذي تطلبينه
24 ولا دوله اوروبيه تدعي اهتمامها بحقوق
المراه والمساواه والكرامه فرضت عقوبات
على خامنئي هو القاتل الرئيسي علي
الخامنائي هو ليس فقط الشخص الذي يامر
بارتكاب المجازر بحق المراهقين الايرانيين
بل هو الذي ارسل المسيرات الى بلاد مارب
بوتين لقتل الاوكرانيين الابيض من الواضح
ان خامنئي مرحبا به على المواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وابراهيم رئيس في فتح حساب له
على منصه انستغرام هل تصدقون ذلك ما
المطلوب الامر بسيط ردوهما من مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
سوشيال ميديا ونديبان 8 مليون بيبول عندما
يحضر 80 مليون شخصا اولا نريد مسيره
نسائيه لدعم نساء ايران وافغانستان ثانيا
نريد من قاده السبع ان يسحب سفرائهم من
ايران وان يطرد الدبلوماسيين الايرانيين
وثا وهو ليس بالمطلب الكبير نريد من الدول
الاوروبيه ان تسحب سفراء وعندما يقوم
النظام الايراني باعدام المتظاهرين حتى
الان تم قتل 500 متضاهر وهناك 50 شخصا
محكوما عليهم بالاعدام وخمسه منهم تم
اعدامهم تخيلوا هم يستيقظون في الصباح
ويذهبون الى السجن لانقاذ السجين ويقولون
له هل انت مستعد للشام قد بسبب جريمه
التظاهر السلمي العالم يجب ان يتحرك الان
طلبت ايضا من الدول الاوروبيه ادراج الحرس
الثوري ضمن قوائم الارهاب
حكومه الامريكيه وضعت الحارس الثوري على
قائمه الارهاب وطلبت الحكومه الكنديه بفعل
ذلك لكنهم لم يفعلوا وما حصلوا ان الحرس
الثوري نفسه اسقط طائر الاوكرانيه وقتل
176 مسافرا بريئا حان الوقت لان يضع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لحارس الثوري على قائمه
الارهابنيه
مسيح تماما منذ اربعه اشهر ونحن نحاول
التواصل مع القاده العالمي مسيح التقطت
الرئيس الفرنسي
مسؤولين امريكيين واود ان اشكر منتدى
الاقتصاد العالمي لتوفير هذه المنصه لنا
وهذا امر غير مسبوق هذه الامور مهمه لان
اصواتنا داخل ايران ستكون مستهدفه ومضاده
وسيقومون باسكاتها فارجوكم على العالم ان
يوسي مثل هذه الاعمال يمنح الصوت
الايرانيين في الداخل والسبيل الوحيد
لتحقيق ذلك هو اننا على اتصال بهم فاسمحوا
لنا بالتعبير عما يقولونه وارجوكم يجب ان
تكون هناك اجتماعات عامه مع رموز المعارضه
طويله قبل ان تكون وسائل الاعلام العالميه
بتغطيه ما يجري داخل ايران اتذكر لقاء
امراه ايرانيه ملهمه في لوس انجلوس وكانت
تدفع اعلام الدولي لتغطيه ما يجري على
الارض تيرانا العنف ينجح هذه الانظمه قويه
لديهم الوسائل الى متى ستدوم سبقه وان
شاهدنا انتفاضات اخرى في ايران تفشل وهل
ستزداد الامور بشاعه
نحن نعرف ان هذا النظام قادر على ارتكاب
اعمال دمويه وهذا ما فعله خلال الاربعه
اشهر الفائته وعلى مر عده عقود يجب ان
نكون على درايه بانه يواجهون مقاومه بعنف
متزايد فهم مستعدون لاطلاق الرصاص على
المتظاهرين في الشوارع تحدثوا عن استخدام
الرصاص المطاطي ولاوضح لكم ما هي انها
تسمى الاسلحه غير الفتاكه ومع ذلك يقتلعت
اعين عددا من الاشخاص وهو ما ادى الى
اصابتهم بالعمى في هذه اللحظه بالذات على
المجتمع الدولي ان يفرض اكبر كميه من
الضغط على النظام الايراني ويجب ان تصل
لهم الرساله بانه لا تساهل مع العنف انت
محققه العنف هو احدى ادوات هذا النظام لكن
هل تعرفين لماذا يستخدمونه باستمرار لانهم
يفلتون من العقاب لانهم يتمتعون بالحصانه
يجب ان نضع حدا لحصانه ايران ودول اخرى
وهذا يتم من خلال جمعنا للادله حول
الانتهاكات التي يقوم بها النظام الان
بشكل يومي
قبل ان افصح المجال للحضور بطرح الاسئله
واسئلتكم سامحكم اخر عشر دقائق من الصعب
معرفه عدد القتلى كيف تحصلون على
المعلومات في هيومن رايتس فوتش حول ما
يحصل
نحن نعمل عن قرب مع الناشطين الايرانيين
الشجعان ومع اشخاص الموجودين على الارض
وقد تمكنا من استخدام التكنولوجيا استخدام
الفيديوهات والصور الملتقطه من ايران انا
اتفق مع ما قالته زميلتان يجب ان نضمن دعم
الناشطين الايرانيين فهم بامكانهم اخراجه
تلك المعلومات ولديه من الصوت لايصالها
اذا استمرت عمليات القمح فالحكومات في
العالم يجب ان تضمن توفير الممرات الامنه
لهم والمحافظه على سلامه الناشطنا
الايراني
حول البرنامج النووي هل تعتقدين لانهم
سيضحون بكم هل تعتقدين بان المجتمع الدولي
سيغض الطرف عن حركتك نعم معناه الكثيرون
في الشوارع
بصراحه سيكون عارا على الغرب اذا ما عاد
الى المحادثات النوويه هؤلاء هن النساء
اللواتي نتحدث عنهن كثيرات اصيبنا بالعمى
جراء الرصاص المطاطي الذي اطلق عليهن بسبب
التظاهر السلم
ون اخواتهم يعدمون وهم يرغبون بالتفاوض مع
هذا النظام التاريخ لن يرحمهم ولهذا انا
نزور الحكومه الامريكيه ونحضر اجتماعات
قاده الدول الاوروبيه المطالباتهم بان
يعلنوا بشكل رسمي ان المحادثات النوويه
انتهت صدقوا نحن خلفاء افضل لدول الغرب
وشعوبها من الملاذين
تصير ايضا على المجتمع الدولي اود ان افتح
المجال
بالسيده في الخلف وارجو ان تعرفين اسمك
مؤسسه فكريه في لندن تدعى روسي معهد
الخدمات الملكيه المتحده شكرا جزيلا لهذه
الجلسه المدهشه سمعنا منكم توصيات رائعه
حيل الخيارات احيانا يكون هنالك قائد
سياسي واحد او سياسي اسبق او دوله قد يكون
له تاثير على النظام هل هنالك شخص يمكن ان
يضغط على النظام فمثلا مع اوكرانيا الرئيس
الصيني تشي لديه اكبر تاثير على بوتن هل
هنالك شخص بوسعه القيام بذلك
اعتقد ان القاده العالميين لديهم تاثير
كبير ونود التفاعل معهم ولكنني اود ان
اقول ان هذه المساله ليست سياسيه فحسب
هناك جانب اقتصادي كبير وهذا المكان مناسب
للتحدث عن هذا الجانب الجاليات الايرانيه
في الخارج اعدادها بالملايين ولديها اكثر
من خمسه لتر اليونات دولار ولدينا سلطه
كبيره لم يستغلها بعد
[موسيقى]
اشكركم على قوه اصواتكم انا فرانسواز
مديتي وانا رئيسه التنفيذيه لصندوق
التنميه المراه الافريقيه احببت ان ابني
على ما قلته للتوبه عندما كنا نتحدث عن
المجتمع الدولي لاحظت ان تركيز مناشده كنا
هو على دول الغرب والقاده العالميين وهذه
دعوه للتفكير باستهداف بعض الحركات
النسويه في جنوب الكره الارضيه والتي خاضت
التجارب مع ثورات بقياده المراه
والتظاهرات وكيف بوسعنا كم منظمين وحركات
نسويه وعداله اجتماعيه بامكاننا دعموا
عملكن ليست لدينا تلك المعلومات لان
رسائلكم لا تصلوا الينا فان كان لديكن اي
اقتراح فسيرني ان ابلغه نيابه عنكم سؤالي
حبيتك قوي
والفلبين لان لديهم التجارب النصف الجنوبي
لديه التجارب النسوي التي نبحث عنها لذلك
عندما نقول باننا نتفاعل مع القذى
العالميين فهذا لا يعني ابدا باننا نقصد
قاده الغرب فقط هذه على الاقل ليست نيتي
واعرف بانه ليست نيه مسيح ايضا ترضوا
ايران من المفوضيه الامم المتحده حول وضع
المراه خطوه غير مسلوقه البعض يعتقد ان
كامل هارس نائبه الرئيس الامريكي قادت هذه
الخطوه كلا كلا لقد صدر هذا القرار بفضلي
تضامن العالم وكل قاده العالم وليس فقط
قاده الغرب
استني بس انا اول جزء
لقد شاركت في مسيره النساء وشعرت بغايه
الفخر اتذكر اليوم الذي شاركت فيه بتلك
المسيره في نيويورك وتصلت بزملائي داخل
ايران وانا اصرخ من الفرحه لان لا احد
سيقتلني هنا واهتف واقول جسدي خياري ولكن
حلم طلبت منهم دعمنا لرفع نفس الشعار جسدي
خيار ساكون واضحه جدا لقد تردد في تقديم
الدعم لنا وقالوا لا نريد تسبب في كراهيه
الاسلام ارتداء الحجاب جزء من ثقافتكم ولا
نريد ان نمس بثقافتكم هذه مساله داخليه
فالان واخيرا لم يكن هناك لقتل كلها هؤلاء
المراهقين لكي يستيقظ العالم اعتقد بان
الوقت قد حان للمراه والحركات النسويه
العالميه وكل اخواتي في العالم للخروج الى
الشوارع في مسيره ليس فقط دعما سيره
ايراني بل للنساء افغانستان ايضا قلبي
محطم للنساء افغانستان ولا توجد اخبار
حولهن ايضا
بالذهاب الى المدارس والحصول على التعليم
كل الاحترام للمراه التي تقرر ارتداء
الحجاب باختيارها الشخصي فهذا ليس هو
الهدف من هذه الجلسه بل حوله الحجاب
الالزاميه حجاب
مع امي لكن المساله الان تدور حول الكرامه
وحريه الاختيار
الاخير
شكرا جزيلا اسمي
للامم المتحده ولكن سؤالي ليس عنهم هل
ترون وجود حول النظام من من يقفون لتقديم
الدعم للحركه ولتحقيق التغيير
الامر يخص حريه التعبير وحريه الدين
وحوريه الاختيار انها حول فصل الدين عن
السياسه هذا هو المغزى من الثوره واود ان
اقول لك بان هذا الكلام ليس كلامي ولا
كلامنا زنين احد الاعضاء البارزين في
الحرس الثوري اعلن في الفتره الاخيره انه
حتى مديره لم يعد يؤمن بالمرشد الاعلى اين
الجيش هو غير موجود لان الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه لا تثق بان الجيش سيخرج الى
الشارع لقمع الشعب لم يفعل ذلك فانا اعمل
بان ينضم الجيش يوما ما الى الشعب وسننتصر
بهذه المعركه
من كنا بتخيل انفسكم في شوارع ايران وانتن
تهتفنا المراه الحياه الحريه واود ان
اشكركم جميعا الانضمامكم الينا وقبل
مغادره المتحدثات اود ان التقط معهن صوره
واغرد انا افتقد رسائل الكراهيه التي
اتلقاها على تويتر
[تصفيق]